[Music]
welcome back
to careful boys where we are currently
off the record dude that's ryan's [ __ ]
you can't steal it yo that sounds heavy
welcome to rug boys you got to come up
with your own rug boys um today we're
talking about our guilty pleasures oh
we're guilty boys today
yeah we are
we're a bunch of guilty boys bart what's
your guilty pleasure come on falling
asleep at 10 o'clock
fall asleep at 10 45. life on the wild
side
is that is that guilty no
that's just a pleasure dude like we're
talking like do you watch sailor moon or
some [ __ ] no i've been i've been uh i
recently started really liking
this kind of guilty pleasure but like in
sync and backstreet boys again
again again
out of all the things i didn't think is
it a guilty pleasure if it was again i
don't know
i don't know why i said it again i just
came out
but
because in when we were in our childhood
you're banned from that kind of that
means you secretly liked it maybe i did
you like pop music in the 2000s then now
i i i train to it actually timmy
gets you hyped up huh yeah i don't know
what it is maybe it's nostalgic or
something dude timmy d got me back into
it because remember when he was on jk
all the time before he abandoned us yeah
um and he says he'll never be on that
show again remember that
because we gave him cove at two times
that's right
uh no but he he would play shape of my
heart all the time during breaks and i
was like god damn that song [ __ ]
slaps big time it does slap yeah dude i
started i started listening to him
training
and it's a different way it's better now
than it was back in the 90s what's your
favorite song both backstreet and nsync
uh man i don't know the the i like the
uh
what's backstreet back is that which one
that's cheesebag
i like that one and then i like uh is
that everybody yeah yeah
i like that one
and then what's
not so much 98 degrees or any of the
other ones in the air well in sync
what's your favorite singing song
um
you know what's a banger that's like
under the radar which is i thought she
knew i thought she knew i thought which
one's that one banger
it's like one of their acapella ones
that's so like the arrangement is so
elite it's a [ __ ] music nerd song
my favorite instinct song of all time is
the merry christmas happy holidays it's
the dude insect has a banger christmas
album do you think yeah it's extremely
almost [ __ ] leaves oh yeah that one
yeah
that's the best acapella oh holy night
is that one the first noel oh the first
novel yeah so [ __ ] good man i
remember the merry christmas one i don't
remember the no that's what my that's my
favorite christmas song of all time no
way really what's your favorite and then
the second one is the mariah carey one
for christmas that's a classic i think
that makes her like a billionaire or
whatever yeah who's your favorite
instinct member or backstreet boy you
gotta pick oh so like i started liking
backstreet boys as a band so i'm not
familiar with them in sync my favorite
one
is uh
how many are there again i forgot five
it's fine yeah justin timberlake there's
jc right jose
and there's three random white guys it's
like joey is that his name
where are they from though new jersey
that doesn't [ __ ] matter
i thought you would have like a new
answer like how many are there though
hold on a second
just pick your favorite ones again
was he the gay one yes
he's gay he is what you don't know that
popular i thought they were all gay no
he came out as gay oh but in the 90s we
yeah we all thought they were gay that i
didn't know i really thought they were
just gay and then they were pretending
to be straight for the fans justin
timberlake was [ __ ] on britney spears
yeah timbaland was the backstreet
i thought he had his own career he did
he does
after the backstreet boys yeah
nsync
after backstreet jt
is from nsync and he's huge he went solo
he's now with jessica i'm sorry i always
thought he was a mickey mouse boy that
started working with timberland and
that's when i fell in love with uh
justin timberlake
justin married timbaland that's how he
became justin
he actually has a [ __ ] solo album
where timbaland made the beats for he
does yeah yeah and that's the only time
i only knew mickey mouse that's mickey
mouse justin and then [ __ ] timbaland
that's the bring sexy back bring sexy
yeah
current timberland is probably my
favorite version of justin
timberlake i like justin and the
timberlakes yeah yeah
all right someone else's guilty pleasure
dude
just one more uh uh all female pop group
what was your guilty pleasure for that
has to be
black pink i think whoa
who's that actually it's like yeah k-pop
there are k-pop games they make they
make bangers really what song what's
their popular song
doggy
[Laughter]
how are you hearing these songs by the
way like how did you run into knowing
about it's probably geo i do not know
she doesn't like any of this stuff i go
i do like [ __ ] uh spotify roulette
sometimes so i just go like oh
i just play and i go oh what the hell is
this oh chinese traditional
so i just
[Laughter]
great i have i have guilty pleasures of
the month or the week yeah like
sometimes last week's
hollow hollow ice cream
why why does it have to be guilty what's
hollow hollow ice cream he's putting
money in the pockets of filipinos
[Laughter]
what is that hollow you never had a
hollow hollow dessert so it's like
it's like imagine shave ice
topped with ice cream with like those
tapioca things
fruits ube chocolate sometimes yeah red
bean it's like imagine a um jabba mao
yeah what would top with the ice cream
it's like a tapioca vietnamese drink
dessert grass jelly with green things in
it so i like that
um and vintage porn
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
we have a different phase of like you
know i can't just watch
like pov like it's the same over and
over and they just look like instagram
girls
like debbie does dallas era
vintage like
like yeah like themed 70s cinematic
golden era like maybe some disco in the
background like hairy rugs you're a rug
boy i would say 90s and
nb4 90s and before is what i consider
like a good set of vintage porn right
but isn't the quality bad
it is but then you know what it it
takes me back to a time
when i first discovered porn and i was
jacking off
and um i just discovered jacking off and
then like it would be a mission to like
go over friends houses and then i'll be
like hey
do you know where your dad's like porn
stash is or like your friends will be
like guess what i found you know and
then you know we were all like latchkey
kids and [ __ ] they're like yeah my
[ __ ] parents out and then like go
like play it and then you know how like
it's never rewounded or like
fast-forwarded to the end it's like at
this perfect place and then after you're
done watching it you want to rewind it
to that perfect spot so then dad doesn't
find out and i just remember doing all
those things that's so true and then
like also it just hit way better at that
age
because [ __ ] bus fast everything was
just like oh my god and then like they
still have the effect on me and you
don't want to get caught you don't want
to get caught that's what makes it hot
yeah you don't want to get caught
it's not accessible everywhere it's not
super easy so like you got to work you
got to make sure the [ __ ] dad's out
you got a window of time hope you don't
see me jacking it and jacking it yeah i
had a [ __ ] i had a circle jerk uh
session with my friends but then we
didn't want to jack off seeing each
other so then we all took different
corners so we we played we played the
porn and then let's say the couch was
faced like uh l-shape right so then all
of us would take different edges of the
couch chemicals
and then but not sit on the couch sit on
no no like we'll be sitting at the edge
of the couch like this on the other side
so you see like [ __ ] heads like that
and then just [ __ ] bump in like this
would you be down to do that now
i don't know man
i don't know man why would i
what does it do for me
let's say camaraderie
three couches just like this yeah you
put it right there right we hire two
strippers they start making off these
are jerks and then we just jerk off to
each other and we just check in to make
sure we all feel good check it out he
said
um all right who's going to start with
me
i'm like you're not touching me
that's a good improv scene partner i
have to
okay my hands are officially in my pants
right now no they're not you liar so
happy
dude anthony is i think he's a wild dude
i'm just trying to come up to ryan's
level are you actually hey honestly are
you actually holding your dick right now
no
is wild
method fool
it's like method acting but i can't go
that far
yeah because i don't want this otherwise
it's a patreon video i'm thinking about
the fans that's true like i would
actually jack off next to steve
that would have been awesome
uh okay i love watching old batman the
animated series cartoons oh yeah dude
today's video is brought to you by
audible listen to the new funny audio
donkey series funny my way on audible
hosted by jb smooth take a deep dive
into the lives of six black comedy icons
paul mooney flip wilson mom's maybely
dick gregory rudy raymore and red fox
hear how these fearless heroes of black
comedy broke color lines and made it to
the top by doing it their way featuring
commentary from cedric the entertainer
dl hughley godfrey margaret cho dion
cole sandra bernard and many more listen
on audible now go to audible.com
funny my way how's that beauty i can
co-sign
everybody's name [ __ ] cool things
that they're saying is guilty paul
deeney or you just feel embarrassed
about watching i'm not going to say my
thing best play face best man space
anymore
they created harley quinn yeah it's
great what are you talking about
is it guilty pleasure where you're kind
of ashamed but then like you do it
anyway like you're scared to admit it on
and off the record that's what you you
should be scared to admit it i was kind
of scared about vintage porn you say
porn every [ __ ] video
but then like but then like they're
grandmas though
oh so the women are vintage no they're
grandmas now yeah their ground was now
so it doesn't count oh yeah i captured
them when they were young that's like
jerking off to carrie fisher and return
the jedi but it's like she was like an
old lady but everybody did that yeah
everyone did that so what are your guys
guilty pleasures then
i'm not saying [ __ ] guilty anymore i'm
going to say regular stuff like you guys
my mine was guilty
no that's endearing because bart wasn't
ashamed i was talking about it earlier
with nick right over here oh camera what
was yours like smelling your cat's
[ __ ] that's kind of a guilty pleasure
right like yo guys
i like this thing like i pick up the cat
from the tail and i go oh you a skunk
and i throw it away like that's kind of
guilty if you watch my little ponies and
[ __ ] animal cruelty is also a guilty
pleasure if you're into that yeah that's
true
anthony loves [ __ ] that stuff do you
watch my little pony road rage when
someone didn't even do anything that's
pretty guilty if you if you have
pleasure in it
no i just genuinely don't feel like
sharing i don't feel like anybody said
guilty stuff okay
we gotta we gotta earn we gotta earn his
yeah because i feel like honestly i feel
like what i say people are genuinely
going to judge me
i said backstreet boys i listen back to
the boys i don't think you're weird
though you're not from our generation
our generation that's your boys is great
i'm kind of judging bar for why
i know what i know i feel it we would
have got our asses if this was the 90s
we could you're saying our generation as
if you were [ __ ] like keanu reeve's
age and he was born in the 16th century
those demons
those demons
those shaved head homies still live in
here oh laughing at them they're still
laughing at me they're still beating me
up every day yeah okay guys uh yeah i i
listen to 98 degrees
wait are you serious no i'm just talking
around nick you go and then earn his
thing i'm trying to think of one that's
like juicy
that's the thing is like i'm trying to
think of like what's juicy i don't know
what yours is flaking on us
it's not really a guilty pleasure if he
likes doing it
i do like that i do like liking plans
with people picking them up and then
going
sexual gratification from that
i love getting out of plants i do like
drinking what else man like come on
bite your dentist hand when he's fixing
your teeth that's [ __ ] cool no look
come back to me i'm trying to think of
one that's like
that's like juicy my shit's broke i
swear i'm boring as [ __ ] dog so mine's
mine's uh guilty pleasure because of how
much [ __ ] time it takes and how nerdy
it is but there's an entire community
online of people that do uh what's
called rom hacks
and it's people who extract the actual
files from like super nintendo games
like genesis games and they'll
deconstruct them and you're able to edit
little bits and pieces of games and just
make a whole new games out of them which
you did you remain final fantasy and
stuff but then people all i did was
program it doesn't sound guilty at all
but cool another cool thing but people
like i just came out with it and
uploaded that as a video but nobody
knows how deep into that [ __ ]
community i have a whole other identity
in that community because you have to
like learn how to do these things from
other people so in order to do that you
have to like be in this mishmash of like
random people in a forum that are all
just talking about oh you got to use
this program then run this script and do
that and literally i spent probably
three and a half straight months just
doing this
and with like no communication anybody
do you feel guilt from that yeah because
it's [ __ ] i'm not making money doing
it i'm just a [ __ ] loser in like a
shed and it's a nerd it's a nerdy thing
to reveal and it's just to make a game
that no one's gonna play just thought i
think i think we have different
definitions of guilt is all right yeah
just say your mind was i revealed a very
vulnerable i revealed okay that is not
vulnerable that i was pretty much an f
word i know
i'm an f word and i liked it okay
i'm gonna be honest with our fans
because i love our fans but i already
know i'm gonna get judged for this [ __ ]
no you're not you already know i was
telling you early on the break that for
some [ __ ] reason it's funny to me
when i see like little people on social
media oh dude that's nothing bro hold on
hold on sorry i said backstreet boys
hold on i like watching midges get their
dick sucked let him complete it he just
dunked on you dude he just dumped on me
yeah i'm a loser i'm a loser thank you
uh go ahead no no we should i'm just
trying to help you so you don't feel bad
about doing a lot of people comedy it's
funny like snoop dogg always posting
stuff right so then i started clicking
on the stuff you post you ever see the
one where there's like a little dude
it's a little while he's running down
the uh uh up here and he jumps and then
something that's what somebody catches
him with a [ __ ] pot like it's a
chicken like it's a little chicken
breast and i crack up but when i show
when i feel like nina she's like not
happy with me
she's not happy she doesn't have a sense
it's just not the same type of humor and
i realize that i feel guilty at laughing
at this stuff it's because you're here
in a safe place you're not just talking
about listening that is that is funny
though yeah that is funny
why is that guilty i told you guys my
game because people are getting that
yeah but it's a [ __ ] viral comedy
video millions of people think it's
funny yeah it's not like you're like
laughing at people that die if it had
like three views why is that guilty it's
because somebody here said i don't know
i like hollow hollow
maybe the [ __ ] uh
bar is really high out here you know
well it's because i've already said all
the other stuff so i'm just going to be
like i'm a little naughty no it's guilty
because historically the japanese once
we're at war with philippines
how about this i got right i developed
games
for myself do you have more that you
want to share but you don't feel
comfortable yet no no not really
are you sure
because i i'll tell you i'll tell you
one but you got if if that's what you
yeah do you think that's my my
definitely my most recent actual guilty
pleasure because i know that people
would get mad at that people are like
that's not funny well because you're
with the [ __ ] bitch-ass whoa crowd
nina
oh no not nina
no she's wonderful how many people have
you shown that to and they they like
judge you for it
i don't i don't i don't know yeah i
don't show it to people anymore unless i
know that you're they're gonna laugh
well you guys know about my game show
sketch which i have sold very few people
yeah but but nikki hates it and every
girl i've ever pissed that sketch too
hates it oh yeah yeah then their
husbands [ __ ] die laughing
bobby lee was dying laughing on pictures
to him cuz you're gonna do it for a show
i was gonna do it for his sketch show i
wrote it for his sketchbook it's [ __ ]
brilliant thank you but i can't talk
about it why
we're talking about it
you don't you don't remember it i
remember it clearly so your guilty
pleasure is just that it exists
yeah yeah the scales of guilty are so
off to be here well no because that's
gonna be the lameness because you know
the way i think of a guilty pleasure is
something that's also kind of criminal
well you know what i mean yeah
you know
i'm a boy i'm a guy and i play with toys
as a man yeah it's like that it's like i
like to i like to go to a comic con and
wear a batman outfit you're right it's
just my definition well like i'm really
into beyonce's new album
i'm not really guilty about this but i
love watching natural disasters and
seeing people kind of like i think
that's hilarious
yeah i can understand that what videos
make me laugh for some reason like it's
pleasing to see disaster when somebody
else was like dude i was there and that
[ __ ] my life up but you're like damn
that was really entertaining for like 10
seconds like that but guilty pleasure is
also something you're not supposed to
like so you are supposed to like that
like your personality likes that stuff
you know what that is you know what's
really fun to watch too are stolen valor
videos oh
yeah i don't know if that's guilty
pleasure i have nothing to do with the
military but i [ __ ] love watching
stolen valor what are those like what
are those videos they're being called
down
for being fake uh military men or like
fake servicemen or fake veterans that's
dope let me tell you something
iraq i'll tell you i'll tell you what
pain is yeah let me tell you what
[ __ ] conflict is
and then it's it's the moment where the
person filming like gets the real guy to
come over and be like oh yeah where did
you what platoon were you serving and he
can't [ __ ] answer 154th yeah he just
gets taken down
it's like the fake jujitsu black belt
yeah those are great stolen valor
compilations bro i love those [ __ ]
great i think those guys deserve to get
beat up oh i like flat earth videos
those guys kill me flat earthers are
saying the flat earthers kill me can you
send me some of those videos yeah for
sure i want to see these but some of
some of their arguments sometimes are
like look i know the earth is round yeah
but the conviction of which they talk
about flat earth you're like
i kind of get it i like your enthusiasm
yeah yeah like
i i would believe that if i didn't the
one argument that they make that i was i
was kind of like because i'm too i'm far
too stupid to understand but they're
like how come whenever you're in an
airplane the pilot doesn't have to keep
on pointing the nose down if the earth
is in fact round and i'm like holy [ __ ]
holy sweet [ __ ] mother of christ kyle
what's in on it too that's an incredible
point
and then the other one is you cannot get
a flight they say you can't they say you
cannot get a flight from like
um you know
um south south america
like to russia
like you can't just like go over the
pole or whatever but that's because of
their tank maybe no that's because if
they have to make an emergency landing
there's nowhere to go yeah that's what
they say but then but then it's like
that's what they say
you should say they you tell us that's a
big enough point i i think that this
room this room uh needs more secrets and
it needs more shame
because we [ __ ] talk about
everything and it's already exposed out
there that's true and there's not enough
guilty pleasures because we're not
guilty about our pleasuring this one's
all me guys i thought that guilty
questions would be hey nick hasn't went
yet we don't know his might be oh yeah
tell us the truth
nah honestly okay look like you like to
watch [ __ ] goats getting older
i know this is [ __ ] super lame but
like
any time i feel
like i want to sit down and play video
games i feel really guilty about it and
i feel like
i feel like it's a wasting time so i'll
sit down i'll try to play for a little
bit
but then like it gets to a point where
i'm like dude are you nagging in your
own head yeah bro i'm like dude i feel
like i'm wasting time so i put it down i
battle with that a lot but that's
probably one thing that if i do like if
if my wife is out of the house
like one thing i like to do is i like to
walk around the house naked because
that's like kind of my thing and i like
to play video games a little bit when
she's gone
here that was even better no and then
also okay my newest thing this is super
[ __ ] lame but i'll i'll treat it it's
like a treat for me i'll go to trader
joe's this is like what i do okay i'll
buy a watermelon and i'll be like oh i
can't wait in the
beginning of the day in the morning i'll
buy a giant watermelon i'll make sure
it's [ __ ] because this watermelon
season i love watermelon right now i'll
[ __ ] put it in the fridge and i'll
make sure it gets super [ __ ] cold
right i'm literally falling asleep shut
up dude this is good content okay
[ __ ] this is good content all right
the people want to know about my [ __ ]
i like watermelon keep going after i
finish work i get home around like 9 30
like 10 right i come home and i know
that [ __ ] watermelon is cold bro nice
i'll cut that [ __ ] in half and
it's a big [ __ ] water yes i'll finish
that half of watermelon
in one sitting and i'll be sick
i'll be [ __ ] sick to my stomach and i
know and i still have like a quarter of
the watermelon left and i'm like oh i'm
gonna finish all of it so i'll put i i
have a bunch of tahini you better bro i
[ __ ] kill that hole and i'm sick to
my stomach i feel like i'm going to
throw up and then i go to sleep that's
my guilty pleasure
was it worth it
and then i cut it into a dick shape
and i sit on it okay here we go here
the next morning my poop is red dude it
it makes it feel like you bled you bled
[ __ ] huh dude i that i live for that bro
you see the [ __ ] spark in my eye so
that watermelon store is good content
do you think it should be a jk reel
should it be on the jk instagram and if
so guys it's gonna go buy surreal
comment whether or not you agree that
this was good content thank you if it
doesn't get 50 000 views well they're
gonna say it is because that's funny now
no it's not
[Music]
you